[Music]
the great depression was one of the most
widespread economic disasters that the
world has ever seen
in its wake it left businesses in ruin
it left families destroyed
and entire economies were left in
tatters hi
i'm rich burnett for one dream and in
this episode of perspectives
we're going to hear from a handful of
historians as they discuss
the global impact of the great
depression
we begin now with the story about the
great depression's impact on currency
both in the states as well as abroad
[Music]
enjoy
in at least one way the great depression
was among the most transformative
chapters
of the 20th century that's a big
statement in a century that saw
two world wars i'm not saying the
depression was necessarily
the most important among the changes it
catalyzed though was to transform the
role of the federal government
in the u.s economy even americans born
to freedom
and steeped in limited government with a
yellow flag bearing the slogan
don't tread on me accepted vastly more
government intervention in their lives
the fallout moved well beyond the united
states
if the great depression had never
happened
we wouldn't have as many international
economic institutions today
as we do if the economic environment
around the world hadn't been so horrible
people wouldn't have clamored for
immediate solutions they wouldn't have
accepted some of the world's
government's
more extreme attempts to find a remedy
but in times of crisis like during wars
people give their leaders more
discretion
war puts the nation's survival at risk
aside from massive outbreaks of disease
like the black death in the 14th century
the great depression was the closest
thing to war you'll find
economic misery often leads to bad
government policies
and bad voter decisions take the example
of italy after world war one
even before the war italy was no
economic powerhouse
despite being on the winning side it had
suffered serious losses
the italian government wasn't quite
broke
but inflation had taken hold by 1920
its economy suffered from strikes high
unemployment
and even food shortages in 1922
the fascist government of benito
mussolini gained power
germany fared even worse with its
industry and population
in ruins after world war one and crushed
by the 1919 treaty of versailles
the weimar republic funded government by
turning to the printing press
inflation was the inevitable result
no one was prepared for the inflation of
the early 1920s though
in 1918 the u.s dollar was worth 8.9
reichsmarks five years later by november
20
november 1923 it took 4.2
trillion reichsmarks to equal a single
greenback
in other words the german mark was now
worthless
under these conditions it could no
longer be used for even
routine transactions and germans were
forced to rely on barter
as a way to buy and sell goods so the
german government demonetized the mark
and issued new renton marks there were
to be exchanged
one to one trillion of the old marks
at this point the united states facing
default of its foreign loans
stepped in and began loaning new money
to germany
and encouraging u.s companies to invest
in its airstrial enemy
by getting the other allies to agree on
a realignment
of the reparations payment schedule the
united states
also began to guarantee german war
reparations
the specter of inflation was not
confined to germany
the austrian crown had been trading at
five to one u.s dollar before the war
but by 1922 its rate of exchange
was 83 600 crowns to the dollar
industrialized nations wanted nothing
more than a return to the state of
normalcy but this was a difficult
proposition in the post-war political
atmosphere
as the winners struggled to protect what
they had gained in the war's aftermath
and the losers were licking their wounds
following world war one the u.s did what
it always did
after a war it shrank its army down to a
tiny force
a hundred thousand or so
the extent of u.s isolationism during
this period
shouldn't be exaggerated the american
economy was enormous
and so almost by definition it was not
and could not be isolated from the rest
of the world
indeed when the global economy bounced
back from the first world war in the
1920s
it was the doing of american bankers and
financial officials
however the war and the tough terms
imposed on germany under the versailles
treaty
set up a badly unbalanced world economic
system
even if americans had wanted their
country to play a major international
role
which they didn't the possibilities for
doing so
changed radically at the end of the
1920s
at the end of october 1929 the u.s stock
market
crashed now the crash
itself isn't what caused the great
depression that followed
instead there were lots of long-term
structural problems in the u.s economy
but the market crash popped a
speculative bubble
and that had a whole series of spillover
effects in other
sectors of the economy paper losses
in financial assets soon led to bank
failures
and a liquidity crisis in the rest of
the economy
with that the united states and world
markets
plunged into general misery remember
the european economy depended on u.s
money flowing in
once that flow stopped after 1929 the
resulting depression
brought hitler to power
widespread misery in the united states
had deep
political consequences poverty and even
near starvation were widespread
and unemployment approached a third of
the workforce
to make matters worse the existing
political system
seemed to be able to do little to fix
the problem
economic orthodoxy was to tighten up
fiscal policy in a crisis
cut spending balance budgets and wait
for things to turn around
but it didn't happen u.s president
herbert hoover
although a successful businessman seemed
out of his depth
many people ended up in tent cities
called hoovervilles
living on handouts from soup kitchens
meanwhile farmers in the great plains of
oklahoma and kansas
and large areas of texas new mexico and
colorado
suffered widespread and devastating crop
failures
due to a series of severe droughts
it was the time of the dust bowl as
chronicled
in john steinbeck's novel the grapes of
wrath and the music
of woody guthrie during the great
depression
the american people lost confidence that
their individual states
could do anything to solve these massive
economic problems
so the american people turned to the
federal government for a solution
and in particular to franklin delano
roosevelt
who ran for president in 1932 on the
promise of a
new deal fdr
entered the white house in march 1933
and together with his so-called brain
trust of advisors
devised an ambitious plan to revive the
american economy
through a combination of new federal
jobs programs
like the civilian conservation corps or
ccc
and the works progress administration or
wpa
and new federal regulations of both the
financial system
and private business enterprises during
the first 100 days of fdr's
administration
congress enacted a number of new federal
laws to implement
this ambitious plan but fdr
soon ran into big trouble with the
supreme court one problem
was that many of fdr's new federal
regulations and programs
impacted not only interstate
and foreign commerce but also commercial
activities
that were conducted completely within a
particular state
in other words intrastate commerce
and the commerce clause in article 1
section 8 of the constitution
gave the federal government no
enumerated power
to regulate such purely intrastate
commerce so in a series of decisions
the supreme court held that many of the
new federal statutes enacted by
congress pursuant to fdr's plan were
unconstitutional often due to the
limited scope of the commerce clause
among the statutes held unconstitutional
were the national industrial recovery
act
the agricultural adjustment act the
bituminous coal conservation act
and the municipal bankruptcy act it was
not until the mid to late 1930s
during the height of the great
depression that the tides of federalism
began to change
frustrated by a supreme court that
continued to block his new deal programs
president franklin delano roosevelt
threatened to expand the supreme court
he wanted to appoint justices who were
more sympathetic
to his interpretation of interstate
commerce
and who would be inclined to see the
federal government as
expansive and as powerful as he did
ultimately in a 1937 case involving the
national labor relations board
and jones and laughlin steel corporation
the supreme court decided that the
federal government
could regulate working conditions
mandate minimum wages
and protect the rights of workers to
organize
jones and laughlin steel corporation
argued that its right to control its
workers conditions
were local matters out of the reach of
the federal government
but the court held that as large
corporations with
connections across many states congress
had the constitutional authority
to regulate the company as provided by
the commerce clause
in article 1 section 8. this case
was the beginning of a sea change in the
way the judicial branch
interpreted the commerce clause and
protected the role of federal government
in regulating all sorts of matters of
people's lives
the federal government greatly expanded
in power and scope
during the 20th century and the balance
of federalism power shifted with it
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about any of the topics in
this episode
the full list of series that these clips
came from is
in the description below you can watch
all the full series now on onedream.com
and don't forget to subscribe to this
youtube channel
turn on notifications and you'll get an
alert every time we post a new episode
of perspectives